the key was using shock to reduce adults
to a childlike state but these
techniques don't only work on
individuals they can work on whole
societies a collective trauma a war a
coup a natural disaster a terrorist
attack puts us all into a state of shock
[Music]
so you're on in the latest issue of
reason you have a piece debunking the
latest book from Naomi Klein which is
called the Shock Doctrine the rise of
disaster capitalism just generally
speaking what is Danny Klein's thesis
and why is it wrong well her thesis is
very simple free markers aren't popular
wherever someone wants to introduce them
people are opposed to it so it means
that free marketeers libertarians new
liberals have to implement their ideas
in another way they prefer shocks that's
her idea trying to shock people voters
into submission in times of a natural
disaster or military coup or war or
something like that then the free
marketeers you use the advantage that
people are not on their god so they in a
very brief period of time they introduce
shock therapy liberalized markets lower
taxes lowering trade barriers and so on
and well the problem with her book is
that it's it's 500 pages long and she
absolutely fails to support anything of
this I mean she fails to support to give
real empirical support that any
free-market here has ever said this her
her favorite villain is Milton Friedman
and she claims that while look at this
quote where he says that in times of a
crisis people begin to change their
minds and that's something that she
pretends them that the crisis is a war
or military coup or something really
nasty in the short film that accompanies
the book she even shows that quote above
images of prisoners being tortured to
give the impression that that's what
Milton Friedman wanted if you look at
the context where Milton Friedman said
that in the introduction to capitalism
and freedom it's obvious that he's
saying look the Soviet Union these new
European communist states they create
misery for their people so they began to
change their minds
in other words not a shock he wanted to
introduce from without
it's the problem that bad ideas lead to
bad consequences and then people change
their minds it's very non-controversial
really but it's something that she
pretends is really it's really that that
awful and which he were Noma Klein's
price to show instances of this
happening shocks that led to military
coup dictatorships that really
liberalized well yeah she can cherry
pick a few example examples of brutal
people introducing liberal reforms like
in Chile like in China for example but
since 1980
almost every country on the planet has
liberalized this market to some extent
so obviously there will be some bad
people who did it and a lot of good
people who did that you can't just look
at the few situations where were the bad
things happening you have to look at the
broader picture and then she's just
wrong the statistics clearly show the
more democratic the country
the faster the bigger the free market
reforms have been even these examples
you demonstrate in your article are sort
of not only just cherry picked but she
kind of abuses the data and kind of
manipulates what what is the most
egregious egregious example of that well
personally I think the worst one is
China and the massacre at gentleman
square in 1989 where she claims that the
protesters were really not protesting
for democracy free speech and and so on
they were really opposing free market
reforms in China and the Communist Party
massacred them because they wanted to
introduce even broader liberalization
measures afterwards but if the students
were really protesting against free
markets well then you would expect that
some were in all their lists of demands
they would mention this but they don't
and you would also expect then the to
see the drastic liberalisation measures
happening after the massacre it didn't
it was in fact the first period since
1979 where the reforms were stopped
because the economic traditionalist in
the party they blamed the reforms for
these protests if you open up the
markets then we're going to see this
kind of
of chaos so they went out and they
almost managed to turn the tide back and
it took three years of hard work from
from some of the more free market
oriented people in the Communist Party
to get the reforms back on track I just
point out I love that we are at a point
in history where I can sit across from
somebody who will very very seriously
say the phrase to me the free market
oriented people in the Communist Party
Klein seems to have an obsession with
Milton Friedman and he becomes in this
book a sort of demonic figure Milton
Friedman Friedman believed in a radical
vision of society in which profit in the
market Drive every aspect of life from
schools to healthcare even the army he
called for abolishing all trade
protections deregulating all prices and
eviscerating government services and a
lot of that is tying tying Milton
Friedman to to the Chilean dictatorship
of Augusto Pinochet why is she wrong
about that well yeah she claims that
Milton Friedman was an advisor to the
Chilean government and what really
happened was that yes he visited Chile
at one point it was a private foundation
that invited him for lectures he did
meet with August of Pinochet once for
him forty-five minutes and he even wrote
him a letter saying that your old ways
of managing the economy's disastrous is
going to ruin the country and you should
really liberalize the economy instead he
was never an advisor he never accepted a
nickel from the Chilean government he
even rejected a honorary degree at a
Chilean university because he thought
that that could be seen as somehow sand
supporting the regime it was a regime
that Milton Friedman claimed was
terrible despicable but what he also
said was that the best way of increasing
the chances for Democratic Change in
improving the lives of Chileans is to
stop the hyperinflation burn end to this
centrally planned economy liberalize it
making sure that there was growth that
people felt more secure because then
they would also demand democratic
freedoms it was the same kind of project
the same kind of idea idea that
Milton Friedman to go to communist
dictatorships like jugo-slavia like the
Soviet Union like China and to advise
them to liberalize their markets
something that left is rarely complain
about when when Friedman did so you
could really say that what Friedman was
doing was he was implementing an
anti-shock doctrine he thought that if
people were in shock if they were
constantly under in fighting for their
lives basically and their survival
economically speaking well then no good
changes would come of that in the long
run you have to lower inflation you had
to make sure that people had an
opportunity to get a job only then could
they begin to demand personal freedoms
and you can earn and democratic freedoms
as well
no McClane thinks that Milton Friedman
is really the villain behind all bad
episodes that you can see out there in
the world and claims that that's the
results of his advice she devotes a
large part of the book to the Iraq war
how how this was Friedman ID she claims
that Friedman was a neoconservative and
really by implication in favor of an
aggressive foreign policy but the idea
was to privatize the Iraqi economy
that's why all of this happened and the
problem with that whole idea of course
that Milton Friedman was opposed to the
Iraq invasion and she doesn't neglect to
mention this for a lack of space she's
got 500 pages to do this if you have
that thesis if you try to give the
readers that impression and you don't
even mention that he was actually on the
record opposed to it again and again
well then you're obviously out to
distort and deceive the the audience
thanks for joining us Johann for Reason
TV I'm Michael Moynihan
you